Hallo Pascal!
Endlich fliegen wir in den Urlaub!
Freust du dich?
Ja, das wird toll.
Wir müssen in einer halben Stunde zum Flughafen
losfahren.
Nehmen wir das Taxi?
Ja, wir fahren in 30 Minuten los.
Ich freue mich sehr auf unsere Reise nach Berlin!
Hast du deinen Reisepass
mitgenommen?
Ja, mein Reisepass ist in meinem Handgepäck.
Super! Ohne Reisepass dürfen
wir nicht in den Urlaub fliegen.
Wow, der Flughafen hier in Zürich ist so gross!
Ja, es ist immer toll hier zu sein.
Was müssen wir zuerst machen?
Wir müssen zum Check-In Schalter gehen.
Dort bekommen wir unseren Boarding-Pass
und können unser Gepäck abgeben.
Ok. Sehr gut.
Schauen wir nachzu welchem Check-In Schalterwir gehen müssen.
Wir müssen zum Bildschirm
mit den Informationen gehen.
Dort steht, wohin wir gehen müssen.
Wir müssen zum Terminal 1 zum Schalter 15 gehen.
Das ist gleich hier in der Nähe.
Guten Tag, wohin fliegen Sie?
Können Sie mir bitte Ihre Reisepässe geben?
Guten Tag. Wir fliegen nach Berlin.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie alleFlüssigkeiten in Ihrem Aufgabegepäck?
Im Handgepäck sind keine Flüssigkeiten erlaubt.
Ausserdem müssen alle Batterien von Kameras
oder sonstigen elektronischen
Geräten im Handgepäck sein.
Ja, wir haben alle Flüssigkeiten im Aufgabegepäck.
Alle elektronischen Geräte sind im Handgepäck.
Perfekt. Vielen Dank!
Hierhaben Sie Ihre Boardingpässe.
Gehen Sie bitte zur Sicherheitskontrolle.
Danach gehen Sie zum Gate 35.
Das
Boarding beginnt um 14:40 Uhr.
Vielen Dank.
Wir gehen sofort
zur Sicherheitskontrolle.
Guten Tag.
Bitte alle elektronischen Geräte
und kleine Flüssigkeiten auspacken. Vielen Dank.
Ich habe kein Handgepäck dabei.
Ich habe mein Gepäck abgegeben.
Vielen Dank.
Dann wünsche ich
Ihnen noch einen angenehmen Flug!
Ich habe auch kein Handgepäck dabei.
Dankeschön.
Ihnen auch einen guten Flug.
Toll, wir sind schon bald beim Gate.
Wir haben noch 30 Minuten Zeit.
Möchtest du hier noch etwas
im Duty-Free-Shop kaufen?
Hier ist ja alles günstiger.
Hier muss man keine Steuern bezahlen.
Ich weiss.
Wir können nach
dem Rückflug etwas kaufen.
Ja, ich bin deiner Meinung.
Lass uns zum Gate gehen, es ist spät!
Wir haben es rechtzeitig geschafft.
Jetzt können wir ins Flugzeug gehen
und endlich nach Berlin fliegen.
Ja, das wird eine tolle Erfahrung!
Was müssen wir für das Boarding alles vorbereiten?
Ich glaube, wir brauchen nur unseren Reisepass!
Guten Tag!
Ihren Reisepassund Ihren Boarding-Pass bitte.
Bitteschön.
Vielen Dank.
Ich wünsche
Ihnen einen angenehmen Flug.
Ihre Sitzplätze sind 4a und 4b.
Vielen Dank.
Toll! Alles hat super geklappt
und wir hatten keinen Stress.
Jetzt können wir endlich nach Berlin fliegen.
Ja, lass uns ins Flugzeug
einsteigen.
Berlin, wir kommen!
Abonniere den Kanal der Hallo Deutschschule
Aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen.
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diese Playlist um weitere
Videos zu sehen.